Hello dear friends, we are delighted to
come to you today in this I like to know
program. This is the program you can
send your questions and we will do our
best to answer them according to the
scriptures and spirit prophecy. I am
David Salasar and I'm with pastor Steven
Boore. Pastor, what a blessing to have
you here. As always, it's a honor to uh
spend this time together and to research
the scriptures.
>> Praise the Lord. It's great studying
together.
>> Amen for that, pastor. And we want to
invite you friends to don't forget to
send your questions to our uh email
address, which is tvsv.org.
That's tvsv.org.
Send your question. We look forward to
receiving them and it helps us to study
to do our research and to answer them in
this program. Uh before we start this
program, Pastor Bor, if you can lead us
into prayer as we want the Holy Spirit
to lead us as we share from the Bible
the answers to the questions.
>> Certainly. Let's pray. Father in heaven,
we have some very very important
questions to answer today. We've done
our research, but uh we ask that through
the ministry of your spirit, you will
enlighten our minds so that we can see
things that perhaps we've missed in our
research.
>> Give us words to speak,
enter our minds, and control our minds
so that our words will be your words. We
thank you, Father, for the privilege of
doing this program where we answer so
many questions that people have. And I
know that we're looking forward to the
day when we're in the kingdom and Jesus
will be our teacher and we'll be able to
ask many many questions and he will have
absolutely certain answers.
>> Amen.
>> We look forward to that day and thank
you for being with us in Jesus name.
Amen.
>> Amen. Amen. All right, pastor. We have a
question from u a viewer in Vanuatu, one
of those beautiful Pacific islands there
in the South Pacific. And it comes from
Gino and the question is this. Good
morning Pastor Bore and the team. My
name is Gino Ormbbath from Banuatu, one
of the Pacific Island nations. Thank you
for the times and commitments you and
your team put out there by spreading the
word of God. My question is about the
work of Jesus as our high priest in the
heavenly sanctuary. As Adventists, we
believe that the judgment began in 1844
after the great appointment.
There are others like evangelicals and
some Adventists such as Ryan Day,
Desmond Ford, etc. who already left the
church rejecting this belief. They
believe that the judgment begins
straight after the resurrection of
Christ in 31 AD. Can you guys reconcile
these two ideas with biblical text?
Which one is true and which one is not?
So this is a question from Gino and
thank you Gino for sending this question
is a question that uh really emphasizes
what point of view about the judgment is
correct either the investigative
judgment in 1844
or one about right after Christ died or
resurrected. What is the right
interpretation pastor?
Well, basically
uh our system of juristp prudence in the
United States
is very similar to the system of juristp
prudence that God has.
>> Uh basically a trial has three stages.
Number one is the investigation of the
evidence. Mhm.
>> Number two, based on the investigation
of the evidence, now comes the verdicts
>> or the sentence
and then usually later on you have an
execution of the sentence. So you have
these three stages. Uh what would we
think of a judge who sits in a court and
someone who is accused comes and stands
before him
and before the trial before the
investigation of the case the judge says
guilty
>> and somebody said wait a minute we
haven't examined the ev evidence I know
everything what would we think about a
judge like that we'd have serious
troubles
believing
>> Mhm.
>> that jud that that that judge is
correct. So what does a judge do or a
jury? They have an investigation of the
case
>> where you have a defense attorney and
you have a district attorney
>> and they're presenting the evidence and
then based on the evidence it's
determined whether the person is guilty
or whether the person is not guilty.
>> Correct? And uh and so uh the biblical
system of juristp prudence is the same.
It's not a case that God sits on his
throne says this one saved the other one
lost. No, there's a universe to convince
>> that God has been right in the way that
he's managed every single case. Uh and
he has to do that before the second
coming because when he comes, he's going
to take the faithful home. But he has to
determine which ones he has a right to
take home before he does. Mhm.
>> So that's the first point. The second
point is that in the New Testament, the
judgment is future.
>> Let me just read a couple of statements
here. Uh in well, Revelation chapter 14
was verse 7. What does that say? Yeah,
it right there speaks of um here
singing with a loud voice, fear God and
give glory to him for the hour of his
judgment has come and worship him who's
made heaven and earth the sea and
springs of water.
>> So, so the judgment didn't take place in
the New Testament times.
>> Yeah. Because this
>> clearly this is an end time message,
>> right?
>> Because right after this message, you
see Jesus coming in a cloud in the
second coming, right? You
[clears throat] also have the book of
Acts.
>> I'm sure that you probably have that
statement.
>> Yeah.
>> Where Paul explicitly
>> tells us that the judgment was still in
the future. I believe it's verses 26 and
27.
>> Yes. Acts chapter
>> chapter 17 26 and 27. This is dialogue
with with the Greeks when he was
talking.
It says, "And he has made from one blood
every nation of men to dwell on all the
face of the earth, and has determined
their pre-appointed times and the
boundaries of their dwellings, so that
they should seek the Lord in hope that
they might grope for him and find him,
though he's not far from each one of
us." And then verse 31,
>> because he has appointed a day on which
he will judge the world in righteousness
by the man whom he has ordained. He has
given assurance of this to all by
raising him from the dead.
>> There's a day when he will
>> point
>> judge the world.
>> Right?
>> So very clearly the judgment did not
take place in the days of the apostle
Paul.
>> Right? uh and uh you know Ellen White
tells us that judgment would take place
300 years after Luther.
>> Exactly. So uh very clearly the Bible
presents the judgment as a future event
>> and the Bible
>> future from the from the time of the new
testament of course the new testament
and it's important to see that
throughout the history of the bible we
are constantly reminded of that judgment
that was to come that judgment that was
to be made and also it explains clearly
through the century message how the
process really would be taking place in
the dealing with the issue with sin. in
the those that confess their sins and
how the Lord will intercede for them in
the midst of that day of judgment. So
the sanctuary message really brings this
beautiful picture and understanding of
how the judgment takes place and when it
will to take place. This is how Daniel
uh in the prophet Daniel we can actually
understand where why and when will it
happen. um and eventually in the New
Testament also pointing out to that day
of judgment as we have seen. But I think
that sometimes unfortunately people who
have
um embraced this new idea or this not
new this is an old idea but kind of
becoming new again that the judgment is
done away with or that there there
should there cannot be a judgment in
heaven is because they they they don't
like the idea of their salvation be not
secured or or maybe they can lose
salvation. but is really not
understanding what the process of God is
and what God is doing for us now. The
intercession of God or Jesus for us in
the in the in the holy place. I think
that once you understand who Christ is,
what he's doing for you right now, you
have that assurance and you can actually
look at it as a blessing and not as a
problem. Uh but again is a lack of
perhaps putting or letting the Bible
explain to you and following the Bible
teaches.
>> And you know the Bible is full of the
concept of investigative judgment.
>> It's full of it.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh you know where does it begin? It
begins in the Garden of Eden after Adam
and Eve sinned.
>> Yeah.
>> God comes and says to Adam, "Where are
you?" God didn't know where he was,
right?
>> That he knew.
>> Of course, he knew where he was. He's
calling him to the judgment seat.
>> Then he says, "Have you eaten from the
tree?"
>> There the examination is being made.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes, I ate. It's the woman's fault, but
I did eat.
>> Right.
>> And so then God pronounces the sentence,
"Dust you are, and to dust you shall
return."
>> Right?
>> So he gives a sentence and then
eventually at 930 years old, Adam dies.
Of course, the reason why he didn't die
that very day because God had said the
day that you eat of it, you will surely
die. Yeah. Is because Jesus stepped in
and took the penalty upon himself.
>> Yeah.
>> But there's an investigation that goes
on.
>> You know, you have the next example is
the Tower of Babel,
>> right?
>> Where it says God says, "Let's go down
and see if they've gone too far." Well,
God didn't know, right? Of course, he
knew.
>> He's teaching us the way that he that he
performs the work of judgment. And then
the next one is Genesis chapter 18 where
where Abraham is interceding with the
Lord if there's 50 faithful, you know,
in the city and so on and and and then
he says, "Will not the judge of the
earth do what is right?"
>> And and so once again, you have here an
investigation of the case. In fact, it
says there in Genesis chapter 18, uh uh
that God is saying, "I'm going to go
down and see if the cities have gone too
far."
>> Right? Uh, so you know, and then in the
New Testament, New Testament is full of
this idea.
>> The man who went into the party without
the wedding garment. Exactly. I mean,
come on. It's so so clear. And then you
have good and bad fish.
>> Mhm.
>> They all come into the boat.
>> Yes.
>> The boat is the church. And of course,
uh, you know, the the gathering of the
net of fish into the boat is the
preaching of the gospel, bringing people
into the church. But that doesn't end it
because when you get to the shore,
>> the good fish are separated from the bad
fish.
>> Right.
>> And then the good fish are taken to the
market and the bad fish are thrown away.
>> Exactly.
>> There's a separation before the actual
reward. And you have the wheat and the
tears.
>> You know, the wheat and the tears are
separated at the end of the age.
>> Yeah.
>> You have uh wise virgins and foolish
virgins. You know, you have those who
have a form of godliness, but they don't
have true godliness. Um, you have uh um
forgiveness can be revoked.
>> The man the man who received a huge
forgiveness.
>> Yeah.
>> And then wasn't willing to forgive the
other guy. The Lord revoked his
forgiveness
>> because his works proved that his
commitment to Christ was not true. So
the Bible is full of this idea of
judgment
>> and the investigative judgment is the
right and the only approach that God
presents in the word of God to
understand how he is transparent and how
like you said pastor we he's given
evidence not just to us but to all the
universe of how his system of judgment
is takes place so that everyone has an
opportunity to know for themselves
Yes, the Lord is just. Everything he has
given a possibility for men to do to be
able to be saved has been provided for
them. And if they reject that
opportunity while they're alive with
they reject that communion with God,
that dependence on the Lord, they, you
know, he cannot res, you know, risk the
world and universe to become back into
sin. So he has to make sure that
everything that we you and you and I or
everybody that is in this world receives
from him, we either accept it, believe
it, act on it, or we just, you know, may
say that we believe the Lord, but we
really don't believe in his word and we
don't really want to have that
experience with God.
It's it's it's so important that I
believe that uh this question is made
but that our friend Gino really um takes
time to not look at the the verses we
have mentioned with the scripture and
you can see the evidence is much more
you know uh clear in regards to the
investigative judgment being part of the
way that God is going to be dealing with
sin and how he's preparing his people
today. And the judgment takes place in
three stages.
>> Yes.
>> Not only do you have uh in each trial an
investigation, a verdict, and a
sentence, and then the execution of the
sentence, but God performs the judgment
in three stages.
>> The pre-advent investigative judgment of
only those who claim the name of Jesus.
>> Yeah.
>> Only those who claimed to have the
righteousness of Christ are examined
before the second coming.
>> Right. Because Jesus has to prove who he
has a right to take to heaven at the
second coming. He has he has to
determine that before he actually comes
to take them to to heaven. And then you
have the millennial judgment which all
of the wicked have stayed behind.
They're all dead on earth
>> and Satan and his angels are bound. And
so now you have the second stage of the
judgment where God is going to prove to
the righteous who are in heaven
participating in the judgment that he
was correct in leaving everyone behind.
>> But there's one group that still needs
to be persuaded and that is the devil,
Satan, and the wicked.
>> So after the millennium in panoramic
view, God is going to open the books.
He's going to show the wicked why
they're lost. He's gonna show the whole
history of Satan and his angels. And
when it's over, all of the wicked are
going to turn on Satan.
>> Yeah.
>> And they're going to say, "Just and true
are your ways, our Lord, God. Every knee
will bow and every tongue confess that
God did it right. Only at that moment
can God destroy sin and sinners because
he's persuaded the righteous. He's
persuade He's persuaded the righteous.
Mhm.
>> He's persuaded the heavenly beings, the
angels and the inhabitants of the worlds
that he has the right to take this group
to heaven. And he's persuaded Satan, his
angels, and the wicked. The whole
universe is in harmony, that God did it
right.
>> Amen. May we all be part of those inside
the city, but ultimately whether or not
you believe it or want to accept, you
will give the Lord uh and accept that
his judgment was right.
>> Amen.
>> Okay, pastor. Let's continue with the
next question. This one is from Patrick
from Houston, Texas, and he has a
question in regards to Revelation 17. It
says, "Concerning the special
resurrection in Revelation 17, which
says, "Every eye will see him, even
those that pierce him. We believe that
those that crucify Christ will see his
coming." So, we know that they were
resurrected to see him. And when Jesus
comes, we can assume they will be killed
a second time. So when they receive the
second death, oh I'm sorry. So when they
receive the second death in which they
were there's no return from it will
actually be the third dead. Correct.
This verse also says every eye will see
him. I take it that it is speaking of
the living. We know the righteous dead
will be resurrected and see him. Will
they see him approach him with the
clouds or see him once he arrives as in
and is in the clouds? Can we also
conclude that the dead and righteous are
in part of every I will see him group?
May God bless your ministry. All right.
So Patrick has a good few questions in
regards to this verse particularly. What
can we say in regards to the first part
of the question in in which he's asking
will the wicked that are the ones that
pierce him will they die again and then
be resurrected a third time?
>> Yes. But uh the Bible doesn't speak of
the a third resurrection. right?
>> Uh or a third death rather. The Bible
speaks of first death and second death.
In other words, physical death which
everyone will suffer except for the end
time generation and eternal death.
>> First death, second death,
>> right?
>> Um the the third the second death is the
final punishment for sin.
>> But physical death is not. Um in the
case of the second coming um we needed
to keep several things in mind. Those
who are alive
are going to see Jesus come in the
clouds.
>> Yeah.
>> Every eye will see him of those who are
alive. Obviously dead the dead not
there's a specialized group of dead who
will which is those who pierced him.
>> And there will be another group uh among
the living
>> right
>> uh who will be translated to heaven not
seeing death. And there will be a
special group of righteous people also
those who died in the faith of the third
angel's message.
>> So but that's not at the second coming
that takes place before Jesus even
begins his second coming.
>> You know the righteous uh who died in
the faith of third angel's message are
resurrect at the voice of God. He hasn't
begun his second coming yet Christ. And
then you have a group of wicked who
pierce Jesus will all resurrect at the
same time. And they will see the total
second coming from beginning to end.
>> Mhm.
>> You know, the other righteous dead are
going to resurrect when Jesus is above
the earth.
>> They're not going to see the entire
second coming. for for um Patrick, I
would recommend that you read the
chapter in Great Controversy, God's
people delivered,
>> particularly uh the the first five or
six pages. Yeah.
>> Where Ellen White speaks about this
special resurrection. Now, are all the
wicked going to resurrect?
>> No.
Most of the wicked are going to remain
in the tombs
>> until after the millennium when they're
going to resurrect and sucker second
suffer second death. But you know these
are exceptions to the rule we talked
about in a previous program. You know
that well there's going to be there's
going to be a a third resurrection
right? Well there's going to be a third
death. Technically yes
but in terms of the biblical scenario
>> there's first death which is physical
death
>> and there's second death which is
everlasting death and the other death uh
after the millennium
>> uh is only an exceptional case
>> and that is the second death that you as
you will mention that's after the
millennium. So in a sense we have to
remember that I mean and we don't know
for a fact
>> there are people who have been
resurrected before
uh you know in the Bible throughout this
history of the Bible you have in you
know children the the the
do this the son of the woman for example
or the son of the widow that Elijah
spent time with. Um there was that man
who was resurrected the Ethiopian that
was resurrected by touching the bones of
Eli Elijah. Elisha. So, you know, there
are these individuals who were
resurrected and and even Lazarus, but we
don't know. I mean, we pray that these
individuals were faithful to the Lord,
but if they were not, they died again,
you know. So, so that possibility of of
being resurrected again to to die again
in this life, it's possible. And it's
not necessarily like you said, the
second resurrection is really I mean the
the second death rather, the second
death is only this terminology used for
that experience after the millennium.
That's where they are resurrected all
the wicked to be destroyed forever. And
so um yeah, so like you said these
things are are you know for these
particular groups they have to resurrect
it and then die again doesn't mean that
they have a second or third but it's
basically just the same experience once
again [laughter]
>> in short.
>> Yeah in a short
>> what this special group of wicked people
who pierce Christ is going to have uh
three resurrections.
>> Exactly. [laughter]
They're going they died before the
second coming. They're going to
resurrect in this special resurrection.
They're going to die again. And then uh
after the panoramic view is seen, then
they're going to suffer second death.
Yes.
>> So even though uh we might say that it's
third death in the biblical definition,
it's second death because it's death
from which there will be no
resurrection.
>> Exactly. Now in the other part of the
question as he's asking pastor he's
asking whether or not these individuals
um will see him approaching with the
clouds or see him once he arrives as in
the clouds. Um
>> they will see him
when Jesus is about to begin his second
coming.
>> Clearly Ellen White makes it very clear
that this special group will resurrect
when God's voice is seen. It is done
under the seventh plague.
>> And then Jesus begins his second coming
and you have the battle of Armageddon.
>> And I believe Christ and I was looking
right now going to that verse where he
tells them specifically that you will
see him, you know, you will you will see
the son of man coming in the clouds of
heaven with his glory. So he does tell
them when he they're going to be seen. I
mean they're going to be there seeing
his approach his coming to realize you
know I mean or to remember that Christ
was indeed the Messiah the king of kings
and the lord of lords. So uh Christ told
them prophesy them what they will see as
as he was going to come
>> right and among that group according to
Matthew 20 26 verse 64
>> there's one individual who is named by
name and that's Kyifas. Yes.
>> Uh Jesus says, he says, "From now on, I
tell you that you will see the son of
man coming on the clouds of heaven with
power and glory."
>> And so, uh, very clearly, uh, he is one
of those that pierced him. He was one of
the ring leaders that pierced Christ.
>> And so, he's going to resurrect in that
special resurrection to see Jesus in a
different light. M along with him others
who were there and unfortunately who
caused part of the the or were the ones
that made everyone there reject Christ
as a savior. So well thank you pastor
and thank you Patrick for this question.
I hope that this has been a blessing to
you as it has been to us to study to be
able to uh see clearly what the lord
wants us to know from his experience and
what he has shared in his word. We pray
that you will be blessed and once again
we thank you for your prayers and for
continued support of this ministry. It
is only through your contribution that
we can continue to present these
programs to you. May God bless you and
see you next time.
Heat. Heat.